So this was a really tough question, and I'll admit I
got it wrong twice myself in trying to answer it. But I'm
pretty sure I know the correct answer now. Which is that
none of these are actually equivalent to s.find t,i. If you didn't
get that, that's okay. Two of em are pretty close, and
the two that are pretty close are the first and the third.
But none of them are exactly correct and let's go through
an example to understand why. So let's suppose we started with s
as udacity. Let's make
t city and make i three.
So if we do s.find t,i, what we're going to get starting
from position i which is n, s looking for city, we're going to
find it right there. The output of s.find
t,i with these variables is going to be three. So
it, search is starting from position three, but it's still
going to give us the output where that's position three. It
gives us output in terms of the positions in the
original string, s. So the first one, si:, where i
is three, is going to be this string. So when we
do the find where that's the string, we find city
at position zero, and the result of this is zero.
That's not the same as the result we expect
which is three. The second one doesn't actually make
any sense. So here s.find evaluates to a number,
and then we're trying to index from a number, that
doesn't make any sense. We can only index from
a string, select a sub-sequence of characters, there's no way
to select a sub-sequence of characters from a number.
So this is invalid, definitely doesn't produce the same output
as s.find t,i. The third one's the trickiest one. This is one
that I originally thought would be equal and for this particular case it is. In
this case when we do s 3 colon.find t well
that's going to produce the result zero we that
we saw before. And then when we add i to
it; we're going to get the value three. So in
cases where we find the string t, in s starting
from position i; this will be equivalent. If we made t something else, so let's
suppose we made t dog, well then what's going to happen is the result
of s.find, t,i when t is dog, that result would be negative one. Find always
returns negative one, when the string we're searching for is not found. In this
case, we'd have negative one as the result for
this, add i to it. That would give us the
number two. That's not the same as negative one because
this also is not equivalent. In cases where t is
found, it is equivalent, but in cases where t is
not found, it's not equivalent. The fourth one is also
not equivalent. For the fourth one we're starting from selecting
the sub-sequence of s, starting from position i. And we're
looking for the string t where we sub-sequence from t starting from position i,
this won't give us the same result as s.find t,i. So this was
kind of a tricky question. You are not upset if you didn't get it
right but the answer is none of these are actually equivalent to s.find t,i.